When it comes to idle status in the Marshmallow,
I always say the developer does not need to worry
And maybe you do not need to change any code either.
But you need to test your application.
I'm Joanna Smith and by this time,
We must know that you can not escape the monster test.
Some quick background.
There is nothing worse for the user
From trying to take a picture of his acting dog
Gently, only to show that his battery is 6%
And opening the camera kills their phones.
Battery protection is caused by idle mode
The system can place your application in it if it is not activated
Recently.
And while this may seem scary, the best advice
I have you as a developer is to do nothing,
Because the standby mode in the application is intelligent.
This will not happen to applications that the user interacts with.
Or which have effective activities and services
In the background, or containing notification messages
Hanging in the drawer.
Standby mode is designed to restrict background synchronization operations
And functions for applications that do not care
Currently in use.
So when your app is used
He does not need to worry about that.
And when it does not, it should not in fact
To note that in the idle state, so my advice to do nothing,
Except for testing your application.
There - so.
Quality Bezel retrieves your application from idle mode
It is important to understand what users may see.
So you'll be sure that any notifications are expected
Created correctly, the download messages are stimulated
The right answer immediately to high priority
Or late for normal status, and that late and concurrent messages
Cleaned in both the daily maintenance window
Once your app is out of idle mode
To help you, we have created a new "ADB" service
Which will allow you to switch the entry and exit from standby in the application.
So you need a device or simulator running the marchemelo,
Then you need to open your application and leave it running.
And then force your application to standby mode,
You first need to order the device not to pull any power from its connection cable
To your computer, because the plug
I mean we are not worried about the battery anymore.
Then set the "inactivity" as true or false
To switch to or from standby in the application.
The inactivity mode will allow you to check the current status.
By switching status, you will know what to expect,
You can notice whether your application is behaving correctly.
In theory, there should be no surprises
Because all background work
It does not happen when running Idle should work as soon as you finish
It is idle, and nothing is lost.
Any action in front of me means you
Do not move into idle mode in the first place.
But if you notice something strange during the test,
You can modify your properties.
GCM messages marked with a tag
High priority will come to your application even during standby,
So that you can interact with the important information coming from your server
Wake-up and alerts are honored by idle status.
So if you need to interact with a certain time, you can.
But for most applications, there must be little work,
Which means that this time all you have to do is test the code "code"
Then take a nap in order to build better applications.
[Music]